this video was made possible by the crew
to a new open-world racing game from
Ubisoft
more about it after the video no sport
is as logistical challenging as
motorsports while equipment matters in
any sport in motorsports the human is
only half the athlete the vehicle is the
other half the performance of a motor
sports vehicle is directly tied to
having the right components in the right
place at the right time so the logistics
are part of the competition Racing may
be a sport but it's not all fun and
games teams are businesses businesses
that are expected to make money the most
valuable Formula One team Scuderia
Ferrari is worth over 1.3 billion
dollars
this means this team is valued at about
as much as tech companies discord bird
rides or door - the wealthier teams like
Ferrari are able to spend more money on
transport to bring more equipment and
spare parts which can make the
difference between winning and losing
when things go wrong Formula One is by
many measures the most international
sports competition over its 21 yearly
races the teams Traverse five continents
with as little as a week between events
a chaotic ballet of trucks boats and
planes transports this show across the
world each year 10 teams compete in
Formula One and despite it taking place
worldwide it is by all measures a
European sport eight of the ten teams
are registered in and operate out of
Europe only the Indian and American
teams are from elsewhere although the
Indian team is actually based in the UK
while the US team based in North
Carolina operates a secondary forward
base in the UK so that staff doesn't
have to travel all the way back to the
u.s. between each of the European races
which in recent years have been held
consecutively with a brief interruption
of the Canadian Grand Prix in the middle
of the season over summer thanks to this
the European leg of the season is
compared to the rest relatively easy
logistically because within Europe you
can drive the cost of shipping by truck
is so comparatively low to shipping by
plane that teams bring whole buildings
with them to European races these
buildings are what are modestly referred
to as motorhomes but can be as large as
Red Bulls three-story structure that
includes offices bars and a restaurant
with a complete kitchen
all of that packs in to a number of
trucks and can be assembled in less than
two days along with all the other
equipment including cars spare parts and
electronics convoys of dozens of trucks
per team crisscross the continent before
each European race typically races are
held every two weekends on Sunday which
gives teams plenty of time to relocate
before activity begins on the Thursday
before the Grand Prix but from time to
time the schedules crunched and races
take place two weekends in a row this
proves a more daunting logistical
challenge as teams only have three full
days to break down transport and
reassemble their equipment at the new
race site even worse for the first time
ever the 2018 season saw three weekends
with three races in a row on June 24th
the French Grand Prix took place in La
Coste let then the next weekend the
Austrian one was held in Spielberg
finishing off the following weekend with
the British Grand Prix in Silverstone
the Austria UK transfer was the most
difficult one as it involved driving
nearly 1,000 miles including through the
choke point of the Channel Tunnel for
this Trek each truck was manned by three
drivers so that while one drove the
others could sleep in an RV that
accompanied the convoy that way the
trucks could drive continuously only
stopping to refuel but again these races
are easy logistically compared to the
ones outside of Europe the ones known as
flyaway races just like with the
European races a majority of flyaway
races occur with two weeks between them
but from time to time races are
scheduled on back-to-back weekends
thousands of miles apart these
back-to-back flyaway races are the most
logistical difficult weeks of the
Formula One season on Sunday April 8th
2018 the Bahrain Grand Prix was held in
Soccer Bahrain then seven days later the
following weekend the Chinese Grand Prix
was held in Shanghai China over 4000
miles separated those two racetracks and
yet
just like with every race everything
came down on Sunday night in Bahrain and
had to be operational by Thursday
morning in China even worse Shanghai is
5 hours ahead of Bahrain which is
effectively five hours fewer to do the
work but in reality the planning for
this transfer began months before around
January 2018 three months before the
first races of the season each of the
ten teams packed up five sets of
shipping containers
each of these sets held their Cicotte
carrying things like chairs tables
appliances cooking utensils and some
elements of their garages they send
these bulkier and less expensive pieces
of equipment by sea as its massively
less expensive than sending them by
plane the number of containers per team
varies as the wealthier teams like
redbull will take more but in general
each team takes about three 40-foot
containers of course ocean shipping is
slower but since there are five sets
there is always one at the right place
at the right time that January shipment
sent the first five kits to the first
five flyaway races Melbourne Australia
Sakura Bahrain Shanghai China Baku
Azerbaijan and Montreal Canada then as
each race was completed its kit was
packed up and sent to the next Flyway
race destination without a kit the
Australian won went to Singapore the
bahraini went to Russia
the Chinese went to Japan the
Azerbaijani went to the United States
and the Canadian won to Mexico and then
towards the end of the season when there
are no more tracks to send kits to
they're sent back to the team's home
bases for the winter at the race track
the Formula One logistics team's main
downtime is actually during the race
itself but for the Bahrain to China
transfer real work began at the Thursday
before the race that's when each teams
logistics manager started making their
teardown plan deciding in which order
and into which containers their
different pieces of equipment should go
once that was completed there really was
not a lot to do until Sunday on Sunday
morning before the race even started the
pack up began many of the spare parts
can't be used during the race they're
not going to replace an engine during
the Grand Prix so they're the first
pieces of kits to be packed into their
containers not much happened during the
race itself but within 15 minutes of
attending the main pack up began the
cars the most important pieces of
equipment were subjected to a post-race
inspection to be sure no illegal
modifications were made but everything
else was immediately ready for packing
all the equipment that the teams wanted
at the destination first were put into
one of three priority pallets together
each team's priority palace filled up
the first plane to Shanghai as soon as
these were packed they were driven
directly to the airport only a few hours
after the race ended to be prepared for
the early morning flight to Shanghai as
that plane took off the final pallets
were being packed up back at the race
track
about six to eight hours after the drop
of the checkered flag all pallets were
packed up and on their way to the
airport by midday Monday all six of the
Boeing 747s used to transport the team's
equipment to China were in the air these
planes were chartered by Formula One but
the teams still paid for the space also
on Monday all the staff started their
journey to Shanghai many of the
lower-level staff just flew on normal
commercial flights while some of the
higher profile drivers flew private
between the two countries after nine
hours in the air the first plane touched
down in Shanghai around to early evening
local time the freight was unloaded and
brought to customs by midnight all the
priority freight was on its way to the
racetrack overnight logistics workers
arranged the different teams freight
into their respective paddocks no team
is allowed to touch their freight until
all the other teams freight has arrived
both for fairness purposes and safety to
assure that there aren't many people
around as pallets are being unloaded and
moved by Tuesday morning it's game on
for the assembly crews at this point
each team had their three priority
pallets and their Cicotte in their
priority pallets teams didn't put the
highest value or most important cargo
they put the things they needed to
assemble first the bare-bones of their
garage that includes the wall paneling
the core of their electrical system and
the majority of the IT and
communications equipment my Tuesday
evening that build was done and the
track was once again made inaccessible
to the teams as the non priority pallets
were delivered overnight early Wednesday
morning around 6 a.m. the teams arrived
back at the track and began work on the
final assembly of the garage only after
about four hours by late morning all the
different teams garages were operational
all in all ten FOMA one team
successfully packed up shipped all their
equipment 4,000 miles and reassembled
their paddocks in 58 hours thanks to
careful planning and practice workers
Formula One pulls off this impressive
feat every year without a hitch earlier
in the video I mentioned how the short
seven day spielberg austria to
Silverstone UK transfer is the hardest
race transfer in Europe but
interestingly about a month ago
Ubisoft brought me out to the Spielberg
from the one track to try out their new
racing game the crew to the game is
open-world meaning that they actually
recreated the entire US
and you can drive and race through all
of it not only in cars but also
motorcycles boats and planes even as
someone who doesn't play video games
much I enjoyed the crew too a lot and it
seemed an accurate recreation of the
actual racing I did that day on the
Spielberg track if you think you might
be interested in playing this there will
be a link in the description where you
can check it out thanks to the support
of the crew - and Ubisoft this video is
an extra one so there will be another
one over video out next week